>>Hi, I'm Judy Willis
and I am a neurologist.
I've been a neurologist for 15 years
and after the 15 years my
patient practice really changed.
I started getting so many referrals
for kids whose teachers
thought they had ADD,
obsessive compulsive
disorder, staring spells,
seizures petit mal epilepsy,
and the increase was huge and
yet the kids had no
greater incidence of it.
And I saw the notes were coming from
the school so I visited the schools.
I'd look in the classrooms and I
saw kids who indeed were playing
with everything they could
find, staring out the window,
coloring on someone's chair or book.
The problem was that the way they
were being taught was lectured.
There were kids sitting in rows
in first grade just listening
to the information or
filling out worksheets.
And I know the brain goes into
a state of stress from boredom.
So it was my idea that I'd go to
school, get a teaching credential,
become a teacher and I did it for the
past ten years I taught second grade,
fifth grade, and seventh grade, and
applied what I know about the brain
to the classroom and found
that just making subtle,
easy changes that anyone could
do got kids back in the state
of voluntary behavior
and they learned easily,
and they were successful.
Their mindsets changed.
There's a part of the brain
that is an emotional filter.
It's called the amygdala, it's
part of the limbic system.
And what information comes into
the brain it will go someplace
in the brain, but this switching
station in the amygdala determines
where it's going to go in the brain.
So you have information coming in and
the metabolic state of this amygdala,
how hyperactive it is, how much it's
processing how much energy it's using
will determine where it
conducts information.
So if a person is in
a state of stress,
the amygdala gets highly active.
When that happens the switching
station sends everything that's
coming in to the lower
80 percent of the brain.
That's the part of the brain
that's the animal brain,
the reactive, involuntary brain.
The only behavior that comes out
of there is a fight-flight-freeze
which is great for animals because
if they are in some state of stress,
they shouldn't be processing
and evaluating it.
But we have the same system
and it doesn't work well for us
because it turns out boredom, when
we do neuroscanning of someone
in a bored state, that
shows their amygdala
in the same hyperactive
state that other stresses
such as hearing an alarm or things
that in the wild you'd
want to watch out for.
So we need to keep that switching
station in a state of low stress.
And boredom, fear, concern about
their language differences,
fear of reading, test taking,
those things turn the amygdala
into a big "STOP" sign.
The question of attention is one
the teachers are curious about.
There's a part of the
brain that decides pretty
on a low level what
information gets our attention.
And the way it works is exactly the
same in humans as it is in animals.
It's the very first place that
information enters the brain.
So what do animals need
in the wild to let in?
What sensory input?
What's changed in their environment?
So if there is something new in
the classroom, a new picture,
a great bulletin board,
something that's interesting,
something that captures
their curiosity.
So when you're walking backwards
before you do negative numbers;
that is so interesting!
The kids want to know why,
so thinking about getting attention
means getting their curiosity
so they want to know
what you have to teach.
So how do you get students
to focus their attention?
You've gotten it in, they're curious,
but how do you get them to focus
on something that's
particularly important?
If you want students to
pay particular attention,
have a signal just the way
animals respond to signals.
What I do is if it's particularly
important I'd love to say
"Pay attention" but I
know it won't get through,
I'll take a hat and put it on.
If I want to say "This
is even really, really,
really important" I'll take the hat,
the cap, and put it on sideways.
The other one I'll use is color.
I'll have three different colors
pens, pencils, or whiteboard chalk.
So when I hear something that
they say or I'm writing down
or saying something
that I want to say
"This is important, pay attention!"
I can't say it, but
I can use the color.
So if it's important, if it's
like level-one important,
I will pick up my green which
means all of them get to pick
up their green so it's novelty,
it's change, it's color,
and it's emphasized and that's
how they know it's important
so they'll write it in green.
I'll write it in green,
they'll write it in green.
And it goes up if it's
more important.
If I want to say "Pay lots of
attention" then I'll use the yellow,
and super, super attention,
I'll use the red.
So they are engaged.
They are involved and
they're participating
and they have some way
to focus in their notes.
It's really important now that we
know about these filters to make sure
that the classroom is
a safe environment,
that children feel safe
socially, emotionally,
and safe to participate academically.
We know only the person
who thinks, learns.
If you don't participate
the brain doesn't get
to use its great prediction and
memory apparatus which has to do
with the neuroplasticity of learning.
But there's one particular
requirement: you must participate.
You must make a prediction.
You must basically
answer the question.
Everybody in the class needs to
answer every question that's asked,
but the biggest fear students
have, the number one fear:
making a mistake in front of others.
So we know they need to
do it, but they're scared.
Simply remove the barrier.
The barrier is they don't want to
make mistake in front of the class.
They're fine making a
mistake if it's private
and they're going to get help.
So using whiteboards,
individual whiteboards,
individual erasable pads,
something where a question is asked
or something curious is there and
they get to predict why it's there,
and then when they have something
they think is a good response they
hold it up, you acknowledge
it, and they put it down.
No one else sees it, they're
comfortable participating,
and they're ready to learn
the answer, because otherwise
if they made a mistake, their brain
is totally into the reactive mode.
Fifty percent, it's
predicted of the facts
that we are teaching them
now will have been modified
to some degree by the
time they leave.
So is it great to know
a lot of facts?
I guess for a test but what's
even greater is application.
So what will be wonderful, what
will be perfect in a perfect world,
children will enter the twenty-first
century, the opportunities
and the challenge with
more than just the facts
but with the tools to apply them.
The toolkit is executive function;
it's in the prefrontal cortex,
that higher brain, that thinking
brain, the memory-building brain,
the emotionally analytical brain.
The prefrontal cortex is the
last part of the brain to mature.
The myelination that gets
stronger and stronger,
the networks that take hold.
That happens at the greatest
rate ever in someone's life
between about ages 8 and 16 and it
continues on at a pretty good rate
until 25 and it never stops.
That's the ability
to change our brains.
So in the twenty-first century
there are going to be problems
that we don't even know exist.
There are going to be opportunities
that we don't even know
exist, so what will they need?
What tool will they need?
The executive functions: judgment,
critical analysis, having kids go
to websites that you pick out
and determine is this accurate?
How do we know that this is true?
Can we find another website
that says the opposite
and how do we know if that's true?
So knowing how to evaluate
whether a history book is
from a perspective that's biased
or not, those characteristics,
the twenty-first century mind
needs and the way to do that best
in school is to give
kids the opportunities
to exercise those muscles,
to build the functions
of long-term goal planning,
risk assessment, evaluation,
critical analysis, problem solving.
That's the best training for
the twenty-first century world.
We have some concern, parents,
teachers, have a lot- some concerns
of the amount of time
kids play on the computer,
play with their video games.
What is it that's happening in a
video game in the brain and how does
that turn into a classroom model?
First of all the video game,
you enter it at level one
but where do you start
playing the game for real?
If you can do what's at level
one on a ten-level videogame,
you go right to level two.
If you can do the task at level two
without any effort you just do it,
you go right to level three.
Let's say at level
three there's a task
that you don't really know how to do.
Then you're at your
achievable challenge level.
Whereas if it made you stay at
level one for two hours or you're
in the classroom and you already know
how to multiply five times five and
yet the class is doing
repetition of that drill,
first of all your brain is going
to get into a stress state,
and there's not going
to be any interest.
The brain knows that.
There's no fun in it because there's
no prediction, there's no reward.
Here we go.
Then the brain has entered at
its achievable challenge level.
That's perfect.
What else does a videogame do?
It gives you feedback.
It gives you incremental
progress feedback so along the way
in a classroom your feedback might
be the test at the end of the week.
In a video game you see what's
happening with your effort,
with your trial and error.
You're getting corrective feedback
at a time you really want it
because you want to achieve the
challenge that's right there,
and you pay attention
to the feedback.
You use it.
No one else is seeing you
make mistakes so you're not
in a risk state so you're attentive,
you want to know what's
there to be learned.
Now the best part of it
is you put in the effort,
they see their score going
up, they get to level four.
And what's waiting for
them at level four?
No prizes, no money,
no people coming out
and hugging them giving
them five; harder work.
What did they get?
Harder work!
That should be the classroom
model and we can do it.
In a classroom thinking about what
level is appropriate for each child,
what is their achievable challenge
level and doing as much as you can
to differentiate so they're
in groups at that level
and showing them their incremental
progress toward a goal throughout the
learning period.
Looking at their work in group work
or at their paper while
they're doing it.
Looking at their whiteboard
responses, showing them progress.
It's intrinsic reinforcement
that's going to get the dopamine.
I'm not giving them candy.
It's their recognizing "Ah!
I got it!"
That's the- it lights up the brain.